Speaker 1: Now, let's go to some other reactions
from people to the blockbuster claims from Bob
Woodward and Robert Costa, including at the top
of the list that chairman of the Joint Chiefs,
General Mark Milley, was so afraid. Trump was so
unhinged in his eyes that Millie was afraid Trump
might nuke someone and started putting in place
all of these safeguards. Let's go piece by piece.
This first interview was Stephen Moore, a
former economic adviser to Trump, appearing
with Neil Cavuto. And in responding
to the revelations of the book,
Moore again refuses to even say Trump lost the
election like he's still on that. This guy is
pathetic and no pushback from Neil Cavuto.
Speaker 2: And I think that those questions
really need to be asked about Joe Biden
and his mental capacity right now. But no,
I never saw that from Donald Trump. I do think a
few days after the election, he had a hard time
coming to grips with the results.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's the
understatement of the century.
Speaker 2: And I think he said he's
obviously still doesn't believe that he
lost. But no, I don't I do not believe he
was ever in a state of incapacitation
where the country was ever in danger.
Do you believe he lost the election? I believe
there was a lot. I believe we'll never know the
real answer to that. But I do believe there was
a lot of voter fraud. But I also believed you
wouldn't you couldn't unscramble that egg. And
then once those votes were counted, there was no
that way. There were going to be overturned. And
we'll see whether, you know, look, I do believe
there's a high likelihood right now that Donald
Trump will run for president in twenty days.
Speaker 1: Understand what he did. There he
is. So there first of all, this is such a
simple question. Did Donald Trump win or lose the
election? And the answer is he lost. And you can
not like Joe Biden and you can say, listen, Neal,
the people spoke and it wasn't even that close.
Joe Biden won and that's it. They still can't even
acknowledge that. They may never acknowledge it.
They're not seemingly getting over this. But
more actually goes a step further and says
it may be an unknowable thing. We may never know
who actually won the election, which is like an
extra little wrinkle to the thing, which
is I'm I'm not saying Trump definitely won,
but I'm certainly not saying Trump lost.
But I'm adding on to it. We won't know,
which is exactly how these people will cling to
the belief that maybe Trump won. When you start
hearing people say it's unknowable, it's a you
are basically saying it's a matter of opinion.
It's we we don't know. We will never know. It's
the scrambled egg. You can't unscramble an egg.
And and so it justifies people having
the opinion that Trump actually won when
it isn't empirically knowable thing.
OK, here's a couple. Here's Rand Paul
commenting on the Mark Milley report.
Speaker 2: But if it is true,
absolutely immediately needs to
be removed. We have elections.
We can't have generals overturning elections that
we have always criticized in authoritarian regimes
where the military takes over. This is very,
very dangerous. And if this happened, really
needs to be immediately removed of his command.
Speaker 1: We can't have generals overturning
elections, we can't have authoritarian reversals
of our elections. That's exactly what Donald Trump
wanted in terms of Mike Pence and may even
have been thinking about how the military
could be used to that end. But Rand Paul says,
oh, we can't have merely controlling elections.
And then lastly, here's another just off the
wall reaction to this. Here's Laura Ingraham
in responding to the revelations
about Trump and nukes and Mark Milley
downplaying the riots of January 6th.
Speaker 2: Again, Democrats and Trump
haters have clung to the events of January
six with a white knuckle death grip.
They claim a riot that the Capitol Police
should have been prepared for was actually an
insurrection, the shortest in world history,
Speaker 1: by the way. It was an attempted
insurrection. Laura, please.
Speaker 2: But today we learned
the truth. There was indeed an insurrection
being planned around that time in Washington,
but it took place at the Pentagon and
its chief architect was General Mark.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine the insurrection was
Mark Milli's. And of course, that's not true,
but they don't know where to go with this
stuff. You've got two reactions basically
taking place to these revelations about Trump and
the nukes in China. One side is it's all lies,
all the interviews, the transcripts, the records,
the fact checking. It's just they are all all,
all lies. And you can't believe any of it. The
other side is it's all true and it's treason by
Mark Milley. Well, guys, you're going to have
to pick one. Which is it? Are they all lies or
are they real? But it's treason by Mark Milley.
Figure it out because I'm starting to have a hard
time keeping up. Let's take a quick break.
We'll be back after this with so much more.